what's going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard and this is the channel
where we talk about all things data
data science statistics and programming
so subscribe for all kinds of content
just like this if you haven't already
and make sure you've hit that
notification bell so youtube notifies
you whenever i upload a video
so today i'm joined by um somewhat of a
celebrity in the youtube data science
space
and that's the one and only kenji ken
how are you doing today man thanks so
much for coming on my channel here today
i'm great thank you so much for having
me i think celebrity might be a bit of
an overstatement but
i i'm i'm very pleased with the growth
that i've had and i'm happy i could
share it with so many people
hey man you're you've done incredible
things on your channel
it's grown quite considerably since i
started following it about a year ago
and you shared a lot of very valuable
insights with a large community
of people man so uh so props to you on
that one
so i'm sure a lot of my audience is
familiar with you
um i'm sure there's a lot of overlap in
the subscriber bases that go on in the
in the youtube data science community uh
but for those of
those people out there who never heard
of you before
this is their first time seeing you
could you just introduce yourself
tell you know the community out there a
little bit more about yourself
and your own experiences yeah for sure
so
currently i'm the head of data science
at a company called scouts consulting
group
so we work in sports analytics our big
mission is to improve the performance
of athletes and teams by out analyzing
and evaluating the data that's collected
on them
and you know i actually came into data
science
from a business and economics background
so i found that my path was a little bit
unorthodox
and i realized that there wasn't really
a very good road map
to show someone how to go from a
non-technical background into this field
so as i continue to work through it i'm
still learning quite a bit every day
by no means made it data science is one
of those fields where you're continuing
to learn
but as i've gone through this process i
decided to start documenting some of the
advice or some of the things that i wish
i had learned
when i was breaking into the field so my
youtube channel is a collection of
videos
that i wish i had had when i was first
starting out i wish i had
someone to tell me that hey it's okay
that you know to work on some individual
projects it's okay that you don't know
i have complete understanding of all of
programming or all the statistics
concepts
it's it's okay that you're learning
gradually and incrementally rather than
be looking at this whole field like it's
an
overwhelming uh insurmountable tasks
yeah absolutely like i feel like some of
the more
traditional conventional paths for
getting into data science
tend to start with either statistics or
computer science
so i really like that you came in for
more of an economics and a business
uh kind of angle i really like that just
because it
the barriers to entry into this field
shouldn't be super high for
non-technical people i'm right there
with you like the way i see it
just with the way the market's set up
right now there is way more demand for
data scientists than there is supply for
it
so if we can help get non-technical
people into the field as much as
possible and give them the tools and the
structure and the resources that's
necessary to get in there
i think that's a wonderful thing yeah
and
the non-technical skills being able to
tell a story
being able to put together a
presentation being able to
understand the business value that
you're creating are also really
important to a data scientist
they're just you know complementary to
the technical skill set
and a lot of more technical people
coming from a highly technical
background
they don't get as much exposure to those
things and so they have to learn those
on the job
so to me it's like you can come from
either these directions but you do have
to
pick up some of the other skills and
meet in the middle somewhere and
within the data science domain you
usually favor
one of those skill sets a little bit
more some data scientists are more
storytellers
and some are more close to engineers i
mean a machine learning engineer is
a lot less focused on business problems
and more on implementing
implementing the models and
productionizing them and focusing on
devops so
uh even the kind of broad
umbrella of data science there's a lot
of variability there's a lot of
versatility
uh in in that domain oh yeah yeah
there's no question about that
like the way i like to describe it is
there's a lot of different breeds and
different types of data scientists
and like you said some people are a lot
they just thoroughly enjoy the machine
learning stuff a lot more
some people are more into the
communication the storytelling the human
side of things
like me personally i'm a lot more on
that side myself
and i mean like we were saying the more
that we can get that kind of person
uh into this field in a way that makes
sense i think i think the better
so how long have you been in data
science like
how many years of experience would you
say you have in that field i understand
data science jobs
especially when we look back several
years ago
the definition has changed around a
little bit like it's been a little bit
amorphous and nebulous what jobs and
what roles were really data science and
what were not
but if you look back how did you get
your first
data science job and how long ago was
that
so i've been in data science for
four to five years i actually came from
management consulting to begin with
yeah and i realized that it wasn't
necessarily for me
i wanted something that was a bit more
hands-on i was
working in consulting for the software
development life cycle
and project management those are kind of
my two niche areas
and i had never done any software
development
or managed any projects and so i felt
like a huge fraud
and i realized i'd always known that i
had this affinity for data
but i thought hey how can i really be
telling these people what to do
if i don't have any technical chops this
doesn't seem to make any logical sense
to me so
i went back i did end up getting my
master's in computer science
and i right around when i was doing that
i started working
at the current company i do now doing
some light sports analytics
and i was very fortunate that as i went
through this process
i was able to learn things in school and
apply them
immediately to my work i was also able
to pick up a couple internships on the
way in grad school so i worked at uh
at ge as a data scientist uh
like a graduate data science intern um
i also worked i took a brief hiatus from
where i work now and worked at a startup
called go health in chicago where i was
doing i was the product owner
for the the lead scoring and routing and
data science operations there
so that was a little different feel i
wanted to see if you know maybe hands-on
data science
wasn't as interesting for me and more of
the project management and
kind of communication side was really
exciting i found that i still
like doing the technical work a little
bit more
and you know even though that i'm the
head of data science i manage a small
team but i also get to get my hands
dirty
quite a bit so that's kind of the
weird messy progression of my data
science career
i wouldn't say that i've followed a
traditional career path by any means
but a lot of the things that um
a lot of the work that i've done has
come because i wanted to
experiment and explore different domains
within this field
so through that i've worked at a big
fortune 500 company
i worked at technically go health is a
startup unicorn in chicago and then i've
worked at
in consulting where i do now which is a
very
a very small consulting for me we have
five people so
we're i've been able to see quite a lot
of diversity and have a lot of control
over my learning
and the projects that i'm doing so
that's
that's like you said that's definitely a
little bit unconventional
but the first thought going through my
head hearing all that is
i think that's a really inspiring like
just just
flat out a huge success story because
just to recap to make sure i
got all that accurately so you started
in more of a consulting more of a
businessy non-technical kind of role you
transitioned into data science where it
got more technical and then
fast forward four to five years later
not only are you successful in that
technical role
but you're actually acting as the head
of data science is that
that an accurate summary that's correct
yeah i mean we're a very small company
so i
only have a couple people working for me
but uh but at the same time yes
um one thing that in my career journey
i've been very introspective about this
stuff
and i i think about what i want to get
out of work
one of the biggest things especially
with creating videos and the other
stuff that i do is i want flexibility i
want things to be very project focused
so hey maybe i work 80 hours a week or
something like that one week but the
next week i can work 20 and focus on
creating other types of content so it's
not that i do less work but i have
a lot of control over my time and
there's a lot of new and interesting
problems
to focus on and that's not something
that that everyone can get
you know i got very fortunate in the
opportunities that presented themselves
in front of me
but that is something that you should
definitely think about when you're
applying to jobs
is that especially if it's not your
first data science job
the first one's a little harder to get
and i think that's a special case
but as you're moving through your career
progression you should be thinking about
you know i'm interviewing this company
as well to make sure that they
match with a lot of the work-life
balance things that i believe in
they match with my moral standards if
they match
with uh the type of culture and the type
of interest and growth
that i have for myself so you know
that's
something that a lot of people don't
think about is oh i need to get this job
but once you get it are you going to be
happy once you get it is it going to be
a good fit
and and actually if you do have some
standards if you do have
things that you believe are right for
you that can help you in the interview
process i mean if you're thinking about
dating
you know if you'll go and you'll date
anyone right you're not going to be as
desirable because you're desperate
if you have standards about the people
that you date you turn that around and
other people recognize that and say oh
if if he chose to date me
there must be something special about me
because he only dates certain people so
you know
that might be a really weird metaphor to
bring in but but
that is how like we're programmed to
think psychologically
oh 100
no the first thought going through my
mind with that was well
uh i was one of the first that my
girlfriend ever dated so that's kind of
you know making me do some uh
do some thinking on my own and
[Music]
yeah no that's awesome no and i couldn't
agree more like over
over a certain period of time certainly
after you get out of your
you know your first job you start
accruing a lot more value in the
marketplace right because
those years of experience they really
account for something and so yeah with
that first job especially when you're
transitioning into something completely
new
yeah you do have to get your foot in the
door somehow but
let's say it's two three four five years
later down the road
you have a lot more options particularly
in the economy that we were coming from
uh before this whole uh virus swept
around the globe
i mean particularly here in the united
states i think data scientists had an
enormous amount of flexibility
so there's in most geographical regions
anyway
there was more jobs out there than there
were data science
talent out there that could possibly
fill it so that puts us as data
scientists
into an incredibly empowering position i
think
yeah well one of my friends um you might
know him as well
jeff lee um he recently
wrote an article on medium about his
progression
through like the data science interview
process yeah and he compared his
experience
when he was first getting into it
without having had a role
uh and then after being in it for three
years
yeah and the amount of
responses he got from cold emails the
amount of feedback he got from referrals
the amount
of um actual like
awareness that he got from resume drops
it went through the roof you know the
cold emails were so much more successful
because they had something to show for
it
you know something that i get asked a
lot is do i need a masters in data
science do i need certificates advanced
degrees
the answer is like maybe it can help you
get the first job
but after you've had a title of data
scientist out of position
no nobody cares they've seen you someone
else vetted you as a data scientist
they've checked that box and they just
look at you like a data scientist now
you're not someone who's trying to be a
data scientist or a data scientist
data science enthusiast whatever that
might be
so i think that's something that you
know
once you do all of the hard work of
getting the first position
people don't realize how much easier it
is to land the second one
well it's not only that like i tell the
story on my channel sometimes but
four out of five of my recent roles in
data science
every single one of those happened
because i knew somebody else
like that person got me connected to
some either they
had work that they needed done or they
knew somebody else who needed work done
uh and it was my first job out of
college actually
where actually that one that was that
was more of a case of go on linkedin see
what jobs are out there send a whole
bunch of resumes out everywhere
and then eventually there was a match
and we had an interview process and that
kind of thing
uh but actually the job that i'm that
i'm at right now
i was presenting at an industry
conference once and then i
applied to a job somewhere and the
interviewer knew me because they had
seen me present at the conference
so it was already a connection that had
sort of been made
like he knew who i was already even
though i mean i didn't know who that
person was
but it just made it way way way easier
for me to actually get in the door
so the networking and that kind of stuff
outside of just your gpa
and just all kinds of stuff like that
that makes an enormous difference
yeah absolutely and i'm going to relate
this to dating again because
i'm kind of digging this metaphor right
now so there's two things i want to
point out about that is so if if you're
going out and reaching out to someone
let's say i'm applying for a job or
there's someone i'm attracted to and i
want to ask them out
um my chances of getting that first date
from just asking cold calling whatever
that might be are relatively
relatively low but if i'm putting myself
out there and someone else
you know someone says hey you know i'm
interested you they show some interest
we've met before
the odds of that date happening go way
up the same thing is if you enter
like in your first instance it's like
you swipe right until like it
you swipe right on tinder with each
other it's a match and then in your
first message you're like
hey want to go on a date with me that
kind of thing well so i'm more thinking
of hinge that's what i use more
frequently but yeah
if on hinge you can send likes to people
without having a match but if someone
likes me the odds
of us going on a date or working out is
a lot higher because they've already
expressed interest
i mean i look at that as the same as
recruiters reaching out because they've
seen your portfolio
and they're interested in in bringing
you know like in bringing you in for an
interview
you have momentum going towards the role
because they're pulling you towards them
um you know the same thing is if you're
introduced to to someone through a
friend
or anything like that that's a that's
kind of the same thing as a referral
and there's a lot of social proof
associated with that
you know um the the person they're
vouching
they're literally vouching for you if
they're connecting you guys together
either in a dating or in a professional
setting
and that's very powerful you know you
don't people in general don't really
want to
disappoint their friends or their
co-workers or whatever that might be and
you at least get a reasonable shot
i agree with 99 of that with the caveat
that
i feel like as a employer in the data
science world
typically you're not worried about that
applicant that you get i don't
think they're thinking in the back of
their mind we may have a serial killer
on our hands
the way you kind of hopefully not a lot
of people in the dating scene have to
have that flag up
the other thing about hinge now i
haven't
i remember i used that one a year ago
that was before i met my current
girlfriend
but um i remember with that one
you could if i remember correctly there
would be
there would be all these i can't
remember what they call it but there
would be these things they put on their
profile
you could like a particular thing on the
profile yeah like a prompt or a picture
or something
prompt a picture that's exactly right
you could respond to something
specific from that so there be some
common points of interest there
and i think that's fairly similar to the
data science world too like when you're
like looking at a linkedin profile yeah
you see you
i mean actually look at the business
that you're applying for
see what sorts of problems they have
find some sort of commonality
some sort of thing you're interested in
there
um actually relate how you may be able
to solve that problem
yeah i mean and one really easy way to
do that is
to having uh have done projects already
related to those similar fields you know
if you're looking within one
specific domain again for me it's always
sports
but if someone comes to me and they've
done three or four sports projects
that i would find interesting in general
you bet i'll probably have a
conversation with that yeah yeah
yeah for sure so just to shift gears a
little bit here from
dating to uh some other project that i
know you've been working on
so dating science versus data science oh
no totally yeah i'm still hung up on
that one
uh medium data scientist who recreated
the tinder
um uh that's also jeff that blows my
mind deep learning for the win i guess
yeah so jeff's killing it seriously
so the 66 days of data campaign
so my understanding of that was
you sort of started this because you
made a decision to
sort of relearn data science so
can you describe a little bit kind of
your motivation for starting that
campaign
and i don't know how deep we are into
that end of that now
probably like about halfway through
almost something like so
yeah so what your experience with that
has been so far
yeah so the 66 days of data
it's kind of a deconstruction of how i
think data science should be learned
so rather than focusing on the big areas
the big
topics you want to learn uh which are a
little bit fickle right
i can't sit down and learn python in a
weekend uh well
maybe i could at least get comfortable
with it yeah but
but um but the idea was 66 days so 66
days is the average amount of time it
takes for someone to learn
a new habit and i think learning data
science getting a data science job
breaking into this career is about
creating good habits
around data science so the first habit
we want to
establish is consistency right we want
to learn
every day that's something on the job
you will 100
have to do and of course you can vouch
for that
and so in order to be consistent
we want to set the threshold relatively
low so at the very minimum you could do
five minutes a day
that's enough time for a youtube video
whatever that might be but you keep that
momentum going
you know that's the biggest thing with
consistency is you need momentum
you need traction you need a continuous
cycle
the next thing that i think is really
important with data science or with
any job any anything you want to be
successful at
is accountability so with the 66 days of
data the only other requirement
is that you're sharing your progress and
you're sharing what you're working on
each day you can do that via twitter you
can do that via discord you can do that
via linkedin
you can you know text your family about
it you can
you know anyone to hold you accountable
when we're putting
stuff out there um we're telling people
we're gonna do it we're articulating it
we're programming ourselves to be
successful and to actually do these
things it makes us so much more likely
to stick to our path that we've set out
and said we're going to do
the last thing which is another side
benefit is
i believe that it's really important to
share your work
really important to
create content and put yourself out
there that is one of the best ways to
have a track record to give social proof
that
you are a good candidate because i've
done all of this stuff
by tweeting every day talking about the
things you're working on you're getting
into the habit another habit
of sharing what you're working on
getting comfortable putting yourself out
there
letting others know that hey this is a
cool project i did you should also check
it out
and you'd be shocked at how many people
engage how many other people
are interested in what you're doing and
want to share what you're doing
and want to collaborate with you or want
to get involved
and that's been a huge positive benefit
of this that that
you know i thought about a little bit
but i've been incredibly impressed with
how much
community there's been on the discord
server you know we have over 2000 people
there
there's hundreds of messages every day
people updating people helping each
other out
asking questions all these things and um
creating a community in and of itself is
something that is magical it's something
that
uh you know i it's surpassed my wildest
expectations
for um how engaged people are and
hopefully how many people that it'll
help
yeah absolutely just a personal story
kind of
relate on that threat of having other
people hold you accountable
so when i was launching my youtube
channel this this was going back to like
last summer
i knew the youtube channel was going to
get off the ground
but there was there was planning and
like actually
actually setting it up to film my first
video and put it on youtube
and i told all my family and friends i'm
going to have it up by halloween
and if i don't i want you guys to hold
me accountable and say
richard what the hell are you doing why
isn't that video up on youtube
and so my first video went up just a
little bit before thanksgiving
so it was three weeks late but better
late than never right
exactly yeah and that's something that
i've been very fortunate enough to
kind of work into my life and that
started a lot with youtube i didn't use
as much accountability when i was a
student
or when i was first getting into the
field but i realized the power of it
with youtube
is you know if i articulate my goals and
i put them out there
and there's 50 80 100 000 people
looking at them there's a lot of i
wouldn't say pressure but there's a lot
of
you know 100 90 000 100 000 really good
reasons
to try and stick with them and and to go
through with them
um you know it's nice to tell a lot of
people but it's also really valuable to
have accountability partners to have one
person
that you can really focus on and they
can check in with you a lot more
effectively than a whole community can
so i i recommend experimenting with that
stuff in terms
of the actual i forgot the whole point
of the question was how i
you know be actually learning and
starting this stuff again um
i think that it has been slightly more
difficult than i thought it would be
sure you know i i'm building my own kind
of
as i go curriculum for myself i'm
thinking about things that hey i need to
improve in this area as i go
and you know i i would like to be
spending more time
on the learning than i am right now
obviously life gets in the way sometimes
but the nice thing is i can always fall
back on that five minutes
and i think you know it would be
untruthful to everyone
who's following along with me everyone
who's participating to say hey you know
i'm doing this perfect
i'm working three hours a day i'm i'm
doing great i'm learning all these
things
no it's it's a battle every day to try
and
get into that habit to try and make sure
that i'm really
working on things that'll make me better
but it's also very rewarding to say
hey i've been able to do this for i
guess it's 30 days now
consecutively and i have so many other
people who are supporting and following
along
i i think the next step for me with this
is after i finish the 66 days
i go back and do a retrospective and i
try and make a couple like learning
paths
so here's 66 days for a beginner these
are this is the kind of road map you
could take
here's 66 days for someone who's on the
intermediate side
and this is a path you can take i i
don't i didn't think it'd be fair to do
that initially
because i needed to feel it out for
myself and really experience what this
would be like
to make a reasonable path but i i expect
this initiative to go well beyond me
i'm planning to do another 66 days maybe
a month or so after i finish my first 66
days
to really just keep this cycle going uh
to keep this habit going because
again for any data scientist probably
the best thing you can do
is to continue to grow over time oh
there's no question about that yeah i'd
say it's
in the long term it's it's basically
imperative that you continue to grow
over time
yeah so could you talk a little bit more
about what
what practically that kind of looks like
for you so
are you saying it's first of all it's
only five minutes a day
and you've kind of put a structure to it
together in terms of the things that
you want to improve upon now what does
it typically look like for you from day
to day
is it writing some like a python
function is it doing a
some part of a kegel project like what
is it
maybe reading a blog article on media
like what exactly does that look like
so to clarify five minutes is the
minimum i expect
most people will be doing this for a lot
longer i try to spend it around 30
minutes to an hour a day learning
a day learning but again that is not
always
reasonable we all have lives and you
know that that
sometimes just isn't a possibility so i
started at a high level
i wanted to practice programming first
i feel like if i if i understand python
i
understand one of these languages when
it comes to the statistics and
understanding the math
i have a tool that i can start
like experimenting using those things in
practice
so if i you know if i underst if i learn
some of the theory
about let's say p values later i can go
in
and use scipy to do some demo problems
or fool around with it there
so i feel to me again programming is a
bit of the
kind of the pencil you're using to or
the tool you're using
to to have a concrete representation of
any of the theory that you'd use
so i went through a lot of the kaggle
micro courses those are great free
courses
all very beginner friendly and that was
my first step
i wanted to make it so that i had about
a 30
learning pure learning and 70
application
and so the kaggle micro courses you're
you're actually coding you're you're
applying what you learned very quickly
uh and then i also started a couple
kind of side toy projects to experiment
with i
have also been reading through this book
for understanding it's called
hands-on machine learning uh for
understanding
one about how the machine learning
pipelines are structured
about how the algorithms work and um
three a little bit how they're they're
implemented in
uh programmatically i also picked up a
practical statistics for data scientists
which is this book uh which which i've
been enjoying
uh and i've been integrating some of the
365 data science course work
which is a paid resource so again not
required but
i produce a course with them um more
about how to get a job in data science
than anything technical but
um that's another good resource that
that i've had access to
um i think i i went a little heavy on a
bunch of resources
um that's fair and i really recommend
people just trying to do projects or
working on projects most of the days
um i also personally use youtube a lot
i watch a lot of videos on how docker
works on how kubernetes works
on how some of these different systems
work um
because i would like to have just a
better theoretical
understanding of those things before i
start to apply them i know that's a
little
kind of backwards on the on the approach
i usually take
but i i find that you know sometimes
getting that little overview of okay
how do these things all fit together
especially for the pipeline elements
makes a lot more sense to me so i would
say that
you to use the 66 days of data as an
exploration
you know you're going to be learning
every day figure out
what learning strategy works best for
you figure out what maximizes your
productivity
what maximizes your interest in the
subject area
um because you know someone might hate
watching youtube videos
and it won't you know that doesn't work
for them they love code review and that
works really well
great do that um but we all have little
different ticks about uh about how we
pick this stuff up
oh no question about it i before i i
have another question but before i get
into it i
you brought up kubernetes and i have to
i have to share this i think it went
viral
there was this picture that was floating
around it was either the data science
subreddit
or somewhere on linkedin and there was
this job description where they were
asking as a requirement
12 plus years of experience with
kubernetes and kubernetes was released
so the implication is well we're looking
for that person who uh they started
getting aware of this thing
six years before it was released yeah i
think i saw another one
for fast api and um
the guy that it asked for like six years
of experience and the guy who
built the module was like i guess i'm
not
qualified for this position
even though i built it which cracks me
up
that's it's such a joke dude well that
honestly that brings me to a pretty
interesting topic
that i don't think i've covered or many
people have covered
and it's that these companies just like
you're struggling to navigate the
interview process
on the other end the companies
themselves don't really know what
they're looking for they don't
they don't have a good understanding of
how to evaluate data science talent
it's still a mess for them and so the
reason they use a lot of heuristics like
a master's degree
or they have all of these different um
requirements in terms of technical
ability is because they don't really
know
what makes a good data scientist they
don't really know what that you know
what to ask
for no and that gives anyone
interviewing
a little bit more flexibility as well
because they can say hey i think
if you can very concretely articulate
the value you're creating for the
company
they might not really care if you have
if you can use kubernetes or kubeflow or
whatever it is
they might not even use it in their
organization to begin with
um but they saw it on google's you know
google's uh
data science uh posting so
um they will want to hire you if they
understand
very clearly the value you can create
for them um
because that cuts through all of the
noise for them as well
again because a lot of the times i think
some of the bigger companies are what
they want but a lot of the times
companies do not know what they want no
exactly and honestly with some of these
things
i mean getting back to the things we
were talking about earlier
when you have a job it needs to be a
mutually beneficial transaction
right much like dating hopefully and so
yeah like you need to demonstrate how
you can provide value to the
organization
uh one thing i talk about a lot is the
storyboard approach
so one thing you can do in an interview
is talk about a problem you've solved in
the past
uh talk about the context of that
problem what the problem was
the solution you provided and then the
outcome for it i think that's incredibly
powerful
and that tells the business that you can
think from a very value driven sort of
approach
but the job has to be providing for you
too like it needs to be a good fit for
you and when i see some of those jobs
that just have these insane lists of
requirements on them like
i mean you've seen them i've seen them
we've all seen them
and and it just it communicates to me
yeah like you said they don't really
know what they want
it's a red flag to me that they want
somebody to be a jack of all trades who
comes in and magically solves all the
all the world's data problems for them
and
it's just it's just a setup for disaster
across the board
yeah you know my thought with that is
let's say they get their ideal candidate
would that person really enjoy the work
are they really going to be doing all
those things are that you you know
let's say the perfect data scientist
that has all those skills exists
i guarantee you it's a lot of those
companies they'd be bored to death
because they probably working on really
stupid problems that didn't leverage all
these crazy skills that they had amassed
so for companies my recommendation is
hey
think about what you really need get
input from the data scientists that are
actually on the team
and understand what type of value these
people are creating
i mean if your organization just only
uses excel
and there isn't a business case to use
more advanced tools
i mean maybe you don't call them a data
scientist but hire someone with the
skills that you need
rather than thinking like way above and
beyond
because if they're coming in thinking
they're going to be using a lot of
python they're going to be creating
pipelines and they don't do that
everyone's going to be disappointed sure
oh yeah 100
so that's actually a good segue into
another question i want to ask you
which is you know you've been in data
science for
four to five plus years now and
at this point has it ever happened to
you that the work has just
stopped being fulfilling or enjoyable
for you
so i think again i was very fortunate
that
i have a lot of involvement and choice
about the projects i work on
and all the projects i do now are
related to sports and all the other
side projects i do are for youtube and i
think they're fun and interesting anyway
so i haven't experienced very much
burnout or or kind of
the idea that it hasn't been fun there
are always lulls
i think that if you're on a project
i've been on projects that i didn't love
after i got into them but fortunately
projects
in consulting and in my lineup work end
and so
in order to avoid that i think for data
scientists it's really important again
to vet the company
develop the type of work you're going to
be doing but to realize that there are
other options
i don't think it's um a faux pas or
taboo
to jump around a little bit more
especially in software engineering or
data science
uh to chase more interesting problems to
chase
uh you know better companies or to chase
uh you know the even a little bit more
salary if you wanted to
after a year or two years at a certain
place so
i i think that in today's world that's a
lot more acceptable
and if you do start getting burned out
it's worth looking other places
yeah no that's not i i couldn't agree
more with that
i mean we've sort of we've landed in
this sort of culture
and this market where people do i think
have a bit of a fear of commitment
and so after two to three years i think
for a lot of people
it becomes a little bit organic to start
just teasing the market and seeing
what's out there
and i mean i know i know a friend of
mine who
he'll he'll make it a habit to every six
months or so
he'll just apply for a job or two start
interviewing
and part of it is to keep interview
skills sharp
part of it's to catch up on just the
newest trends like what big tech
companies are doing
and part of it is well yeah it's at the
end of the day it is about
knowing your value and if somebody out
there is offering you a lot more
that's that's something that you have to
know and that's something you have to
consider
yeah i think you know one i
would like to caveat what i just said is
it is important to remember that the
grass
is always greener or it seems like that
and you should in the current company
you're working at a bird in the hand is
always worth
uh more than two in the bush and so if
you should explore your options within
your current company you know tell your
boss hey i want to work on these
problems
like most companies are trying to keep
their employees happy
that's something that a good company
should be doing yes and if you're at a
good company you like the culture there
are a lot of good things about it
you can always ask it never hurts to ask
and say hey these are types of problems
i'm interested in working on
uh can i you know do you think i'd be
able to pivot my role to do this
uh have as a company thought about doing
that that's very proactive and
you might be able to talk your way into
a promotion or talk away into a new
project
or talk away into a lot of these things
um and also
if you are looking outside you can use
that as leverage
internally to say hey i'm worth this
much in the open market can i get a
raise
you know that's i think very normal some
people are afraid to ask
but one thing i've learned in my life is
that if you
do not ask you will never know
and you'll be very surprised at when
people
say yes like i had a friend um
every time he went to chipotle like
different chipotle
he'd ask if he could have the meal for
free
and they've legitimately given him free
meals a couple times
no english yeah you never know you
literally never know
it wasn't just a pillow there's a bunch
of different restaurants but you know
it's
i don't recommend that everyone doing
that do that he was kind of doing a
little social experiment
well because he kind of looked like an
[ __ ] and he's an absolute [ __ ] but
hopefully doesn't watch this so there is
the one technique with chipotle
specifically where
you go in there where it's really busy
right and you double up on everything
you get the double rice the double beans
the double
meat and you get the guac and obviously
the guac is extra and because it's
really busy
you kind of bank on that information
that you got extra everything
not making its way to the cash register
so i mean you're basically you're kind
of because once you get all that extra
stuff it basically doubles the price of
your meal so you're
essentially getting like a free meal
from that but that's taking it to a
whole other level
yeah i mean it never hurts to ask right
i mean that again you could look like
kind of a doofus if you're doing it all
the time but
um that to me is just a good story of
you know you we really never do know
there's someone might be having a really
great day and they want to make someone
else's day um
it's it's fascinating as humans we're
always trapped in our own minds
but we don't think about the
possibilities that could be out there
yeah no and i think just generally
trying to get organizations or
leadership to change in their ways
um from some experience i've had trying
to go down that road and that can be one
of the most difficult things you'll ever
do in your whole career
uh but also potentially one of the most
fulfilling and
ultimately rewarding to your point
absolutely
yeah so let me ask you this because
there's a lot of uncertainty out there i
think with
with the future of data science and
where people exactly see themselves like
where the career path of data science
ultimately leads to
and i think a big reason for that is the
field is so
new like if you take statisticians that
role's been around for
decades and decades so there's kind of a
history there of other people who've
kind of gotten into that line of work
and retired there with data science that
that doesn't really exist so i'm curious
where
you sort of see yourself in like 10 to
20 years
do you think you'll still be in a real
technical capacity
do you think you'll be in more of a
domain expertise sort of
sort of situation do you think you'll be
back in a business management
sort of sort of sort of role like where
do you see yourself
honestly i have trouble thinking more
than a couple years out
um because i i realized a while ago
that it's nice to have good ambitious
goals whatever that might be most of
those for me
are not necessarily career related yeah
and
i really enjoy what i do i love the
process of learning i love the process
of
figuring out what's next or and then
foreseeable six months two years out
and um you know i i've
become a lot more interested in
evaluating
opportunities as they come rather than
trying to
kind of strong-arm opportunities so i
could be in any of those roles
realistically if i felt like it was a
great fit
or it was a a good match for me
at the current time so i know that's not
exactly a great answer
um in terms of where i see the data
science field going in general
i think that it's probably going to
diverge a little bit so we'll see
more data scientists that are focused on
business understanding and
implementation
more to consult consulting capacity
helping to under the business side
understand
what's going on in the technical side
and there'll be another
kind of branch that is more focused on
the
machine learning engineering and the
heavily technical implementation side
um i don't think that the algorithm side
is going to go
is going to ever not be important but we
have really good packages there's
advances in auto ml there's a lot of
advancements
in tools that help you train and create
models
and so that element of data science i
don't think is going to be as prevalent
you know
it's going to be a lot more about
applying the models that we have
then building new models or anything
along those lines so
it'll i think we'll have kind of a
software engineering
data scientist and a consulting style
data scientist that's kind of my
how i see the future and who knows where
i'll be
interesting yeah i couldn't agree more
with that
perspective that eventually we're going
to have divergence because right now the
field
there's too much going on in there i
mean to our point earlier about how
there's different
breeds of data scientists yeah there's
so much going on with needing to
to know all the technical sides of
things
um how to tell a compelling story the
business side of things
stats like i get it there's a lot there
so
to that point would you say let's say
somebody's in school right now or
they're very early on in their career
and they're a very
very technical person do you think that
person has anything to be afraid of
about their job being automated
or their job being like something like
auto ml
just reaching a much higher level of
maturity and kind of
kind of getting to where they don't have
a job anymore does that make sense
do you think that that's a legitimate
concern or do you think that's one of
those overblown
things that's just put up there for uh
for people to make click made articles
based off of
i think it's way overblown i mean we
still have a ton of software engineers
we look at something let's take a
completely different field like
accounting
right we have software that should be
able to automate
all accounting right now right in theory
we should be able to completely
remove that at a corporate level at any
level
there's still plenty of accountants i
don't think the field is is losing
uh credibility or there's any less
accountants than there used to be
right i mean we've had technology to
i mean turbo tax does it a little bit
but we've had technology that should
be able to automate a lot of this for
the last 10 years easily and
i don't think that there's any real
change in the number of accountants or
anything like that there's still roles
they're still hiring new people
because there's nuance within the types
of accounting there's
there's things that are edge cases
there's
uh i would assume as
company or corporate infrastructure
evolves there's new types
of things that have to change within
accounting as well and data science is
no different you know there's different
tools that come up
someone's going to have to pull the
lever at the very least to get these
algorithms to run and they're going to
want people that have an understanding
of how
how these things work so if something
goes wrong you can diagnose it you can
fix it
so maybe it's going to be less hands-on
but it's the very least going to be
oversight
yeah no i i basically 100 agree with
that i hadn't thought about the
the whole accounting and taxes thing and
how that's not been automated
i mean to a to a great extent i really
haven't thought about it before in those
terms so that's a really
that's a really interesting analogy
there
all right so we're hitting uh the top of
the hour here so
i actually have one final question for
you and this is a big one you ready
hit me all right and that is what is
your
single biggest tip for somebody just
getting into this field for the first
time
so somebody very early in their career
or somebody who's just coming out of
school
they want to get into data science and
make a bit a
big fulfilling career out of it what's
your one tip for that person
so i think my biggest tip is to
realize that you're capable of growth
i've talked we talked about this before
i've talked about before with a lot of
people it's the idea of a growth mindset
and to realize just because you don't
know something now doesn't mean that
tomorrow or in a week or in a month
you'll be able to pick it up and
completely understand it and look back
and say oh that was pretty easy now i
get it
right there are plenty of concepts that
i learned and when i was starting out
i was completely overwhelmed i thought
that this would be impossible for me to
pick up
and i look back now and they're it's so
simple to me
and that's something that a lot of
people
lose faith in is that they really they
think that they're not good enough or
they can't do it or then they'll be able
to do it
but the truth is that it just takes some
time it takes some effort it takes being
patient with yourself
and it also takes tracking your progress
to see how far you've come
if we don't know how far we've come we
get really discouraged but
you know every day i track my youtube
progress attract
the things that i've learned and i can
look back over the last almost
two years and tell you how far i've come
and that's incredibly rewarding for me
because i see a incredible amount of
growth and change it shows to me and
reinforces to me every day
that i can grow and i can change and i
can become a better can
um and that's maybe more of a
philosophical
than a pure data science message but if
there's one thing that
i think can help someone learn the field
and maybe have a more fulfilling life is
that
uh is to realize that idea of the growth
mindset and seeing yourself
improve over time and uh you know i know
i said that was the last question but
that brings me to
kind of a natural follow-up here when
you talk about the growth mindset
that applies to more aspects of life
than just data science
obviously and so because i know you're a
very
well-read person you have any uh books
to recommend on that thread
uh yes probably too many to count
um one book that is a little bit
like it's very self healthy but i think
it really helps you to
understand the growth mindset very well
is it's called awaken the giant within
by tony robbins and it's it's one of
these books where
you really take an audit of your life
you really take an audit
of the things you have control over and
the things you don't have control over
and i probably should read it again i
read it maybe 10 years ago
but it really helped me to chart out a
path for okay these are the things that
i find valuable
these are things i care about these are
the things i need to work on these are
the
broader goals that i have that are
attainable
and how do i go about legitimately
achieving them
and my goals have changed a lot since i
made that hour since i read that and
made those lists but
i think the concepts really hold true uh
to this day
also the four disciplines of execution
is great for tracking your work and
understanding
accountability and a lot of those things
oh yeah awesome all right ken thanks so
much for uh for coming on here i think
you have a lot a very
motivational story and a lot of very
good insights out there for people so
again thanks so much thank you so much
for having me
yeah for sure now for those of the rest
of you out there thanks so much for
watching this video make sure you
subscribe to ken's channel
link will be in the description to that
make sure you smash the like button to
this video and i'll see you all in the
not so distant future
until then richard and ken out